[Musique]
pour bien des gens ici voiture
électrique rime avant tout avec tesla et
à l'échelle mondiale le paysage est bien
différente
tesla a terminé l'année 2010 est au
troisième rang tout juste devant bmw et
loin devant tous les constructeurs
traditionnels mais les deux premières
places reviennent à des constructeurs
chinois et c'est normal les
consommateurs chinois pour acheter l'an
dernier 600 mille voitures électriques
la moitié de tous qui s'est vendu dans
le monde entier
il la domination chinoise est encore
plus grande du côté de la fabrication
des batteries avec presque 70% de
production mondiale il faut dire que la
chine a tout à gagner et le constructeur
des grecs des le résume bien en disant
vouloir transformer le fléau de la
pollution en occasions d'affaires et
parmi elles pourquoi pas conquérir le
marché nord américain